[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناو لان السبيل الوحيد
للتسويه هو الحل السياسي بملكيه سوريه
خالصه بعد 12 عاما من العزله سوريا تعود
الى الجامعه العربيه مع دعوات للحكومه
السوريه بحل سياسي وعوده العلاجين
السودان تعيش رابع اسابيع النزاع المسلح
رغم الهدنه اشتباكات في الخرطوم واجلاء
مستمر الى جده
السعوديه تعلن ميزانيه الربع الاول من
العام الجاري تسجيل عجز بنحو ثلاثه
مليارات ريال
في الرابعه ايضا
مع اخواته مع عائلته مع اهله يعني
علاقه بين اسرتين تركيا وسعوديه زلزال
تركيا يعيد قصه طفلين نجران الى الوجه
[موسيقى]
فعاليات مهرجان افلام السعوديه تستمر في
الظهران 78 عرضا سينمائيا حتى الخميس
المقبل
بعد 12 عاما من العزله تعود سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه بعد اجتماع طارئ لوزراء
الخرجات العرب في القاهره قبل القرار
الصادر بعد الاجتماع باستئناف مشاركه
الوفود السوريه في اجتماعات مجلس الجامعه
وجميع المنظمات والاجهزه التابعه لها
اعتبارا من السابع من مايو واكد القرار
على ضروره اتخاذ خطوات عمليه وفاعله
للتدرج نحو حل الازمه السوريه وفق مبدا
الخطوه مقابل الخطوه وجدد القرار الالتزام
بالحفاظ على سياده سوريا ووحده اراضيها
ورحب بالبيانات الصادره عن اجتماعي جده
وعمان بشان سوريا خلال الاسابيع الاخيره
كما اشار القرار الى تشكيل لجنه وزاريه
مكونه من السعوديه والاردن ومصر والعراق
ولبنان والامين العام للجامعه العربيه
لمتابعه تنفيذ بيان عمان والاستمرار في
الحوار المباشر مع دمشق
وزير الخرجات المصري سامح شكري اكد ان
الحسم العسكريه في سوريا امر غير واقعي
ويجب ايجاد تسويه سياسيه لان السبيل
الوحيد للتسويه هو الحل السياسي بملكيه
سوريه خالصه دون املاءات خارجيه
واستيفاء الاجراءات المرتبطه بتحقيق
التوافق الوطني بين الاشقاء السوريين
وبناء الثقه ومواصله اجتماعات اللجنه
الدستوريه على نحو يتمشى مع المرجعيات
الدوليه وقرار مجلس الامن رقم 22 54
وبما يلبي تطلعات الشعب السوري ويحقق
اماله المشروع في غدا افضل
ويضمن الحفاظ على وحده سوريا وسيادتها
وسلامتها الاقليميه وعروباتها وينهي كل
مظاهر التدخلات الخارجيه في شؤونها بما في
ذلك الاعتداءات على اراضيها
ازمته السودان كانت ايضا على جنته اجتماع
القاهره وقد تحدثت مصادر العربيه عن تبني
وزراء الخارجيه العرب لمشروع قرار يعمل
على معالجه اسباب الازمه في السودان يؤكد
مشروع القرار على الاحترام الكامل لسياده
السودان والسعيل وقف كامل ومستدام لاطلاق
النار ويؤكد مشروع قرار وزراء الخارجات
العرب على رفض اي تدخلات خارجيه في الشان
السوداني واهميه الحفاظ على مؤسسات الدوله
في هذا البلد كما اشار مشروع القرار الى
العمل على تشكيل مجموعه اتصال للعمل على
حل الازمه
وقد تلقى الامين العام للجامعه العربيه
رساله من الاطراف الموقعه على الاتفاق
الاطار في السودان حول المتوقع من الجامعه
لوقف المعارك في السودان وفق المتحدثه
باسم الامين العام للجامعه واضاف
المتحدثان الاطراف المدنيه الموقعه على
الاتفاق طلبت من الامين العام احمد ابو
الغيط التواصل مع قيادات الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع ودعوتهما لوقف الحرب ورفض
التدخلات الخارجيه ودعم العمليات السياسيه
والمشاركه فيها والتوصل الى سلطه مدنيه
بموجب ترتيبات دستوريه جديده
حول اخر التطورات الميدانيه في السودان
افاد مراسل العربيه بوقوع اشتباكات في
العاصمه الخرطوم وسط التحليق مكثف
للطائرات الحربيه وسماع دوي قذائفه ومدافع
قبل ذلك اعلن الجيش السوداني تصدق قوته
لهجوم شنته قوات الدعم السريع على قياده
قوه الدفاع الجوي مقتل عدد من المهاجمين
والتدمير عرباتهم وكانت الاشتباكات ودوي
الانفجارات تجددت في مناطق متفرقه من
الخرطوم وسط معارك في محيط القصر الجمهوري
وشارع المطار وتحليق لطيران الجيش
[موسيقى]
مباشره نذهب الان الى القاهره والمؤتمر
الصحفي بعد اجتماع الجامعه العربيه
شاهدت الدوره غير العاديه على المستوى
الوزاري المخصصه لمناقشه تطورات الاوضاع
في سوريا
تبادلا لوجهات النظر حول سبل تفعيل الدور
العربي القيادي في حل هذه الازمه الممتده
وبما يهدف بالاساس الى تسيير الوصول الى
السويسيه شامله لها تنهي معناه الشعب
السوري الشقيق وتحافظ وتحفظ وحده وسلامه
وعروبه بلاده اتزاخا مع
المرجعيات الدوليه للحل وقرار مجلس الامن
رقم 22 54
توافقت الدول المشاركه في الاجتماع لانه
لا حل عسكري لهذه الازمه ولا ضروره مواصله
وتكثيف الجهود العربيه الجماعيه للاسهام
في حلها
تم اعتماد قرار يتضمن دعم الدول الاعضاء
للخطوات المتخذه على صعيد تفعيل الدور
العربي في حل الازمه السوريه
وتاييد ما توصلت اليه اجتماعات الجده
وعمان من بلوره مقاربه فيزيه وفق منهجيه
خطوه مقابل خطوه وبما يهدف الى معالجه
جميع التبعات الازمه السياسيه والامنيه
والانسانيه
اتخذت الدول العربيه قرارا باستئناف
مشاركه وفد الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في
اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه وجميع
المنظمات والاجهزه التابعه لها اعتبارا من
اليوم 7 مايو 2023
اكرر مجددا على ضروره وفاء كل من الحكومه
السوريه والقوه الوطنيه والمكونات السوريه
والمجتمع الدولي والدول المعنيه بالازمه
بالتزاماتها كل اتجاه الاخر ففي الوقت
الذي تطلع تطلع به الدول العربيه
بمسؤوليتها في دفع الحل السياسي للازمه في
سياق الجمود الدولي الحالي فان على
الحكومه السوريه وكل الاطراف سالفه الذكر
المسؤوليه الرئيسيه في الوصول لهذا الحل
وتنفيذ الالتزامات ذات الصله لكي تعود
سوريا الى السوريين موحده ومستقره ومستقله
كما نسعى جميعا
فيما يخص السودان فان المجلس الوزاري
العربي ابتاع عقد دوره غير عاديه نظرا
لتطورات الخط الاخيره والخطيره وظروف
الدقيقه التي يمر بها السودان الشقيق
والتي بلغت ذروتها منذ 15 ابريل الماضي
والتي لا يقتصر تاثيرها على السودان
وشعبها وشعبه ولكن يمتد الى كل دول الجوار
السودان وعلى راسها مصر وكل دول المنطقه
عددهم ما يجمع السودان بتلك الدول من
علاقات متشعبه في مختلف المجالات
ان الموقف المصري منذ بدء الفتره
الانتقاليه في السودان ارتكز على دعم
السودان على كافه المستويات
والمطالبه بوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار
والاشتباكات المسلحه حرصا على حياه
المدنيين وحفاظا على مقدرات الدوله
السودانيه شقيقه ودعم الجهود العربيه
لحلحله الازمه انطلاقا من الارتباط الامن
القومي الى البلدين كل منهما بالاخر وحفت
مصر الاشقاء في السودان على الحوار والعمل
معا كشركاء لافخواصماء هناك اهميه وضروره
بالغه للتحرك العربي السريع والمؤثر حاليا
ومن هنا جاء قرار انشاء لجنه اتصال من بين
اعضاء الجامعه العربيه
تهدف لوقف اطلاق النار والسماح بالممرات
الانسانيه لاحتياجات المدنيين والحفاظ على
مؤسسات الدوله وعدم تعريضها للخطر
الانهيار الذي يهددها حاليا
وكعادتها في
موقفها الثابت من الترحيب باشقائها
السودانيين استقبلت مصر
اندلاع الازمه حتى الان عدد وفير من
المواطنين السودانيين كما ساهمت في اجلاء
نحو 4000 من الرعايه الاجانب في السودان
خلال نفس الفتره هناك حتميه لعوده للحوار
السياسي في السودان في هذه اللحظه
التاريخيه الفارقه والتي يتعرض فيها الوطن
الوطن لاخطار وجوديه ووضع اعتبارات مصلحه
السودان وامنه فوق اي اعتبارات ضيقه اخرى
ناحيه اخرى ان عقدت اليوم دوره غير عاديه
على المستوى الوزاري لمناقشه تطورات
الاوضاع في فلسطين تم خلالها تناول
التحديات التي تواجه القضيه الفلسطينيه
وسبل مواجهه الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على
حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني وكيفيه العمل على
احياء العمليه السياسيه واطلاق عمليه
تفوضيه تهدف لتحقيق السلام العادل والشامل
وانشاء الدوله الفلسطينيه على حدود الرابع
من يونيو
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه شكرا على حسن
الاستماع ويتفضل معالي الامين العام
شكرا شكرا سياده الرئيس انا الحقيقه ليس
لدي
نقاط استطيع ان اطرحها اتوقع الكثير من
الاسئله ولما كنت اتوقع هذه الاسئله
فيهمني ان انا اصدقائها
ببعض النقاط لعلها تفتح الطريق للاسئله
القرارين
تم تبنيهم النهارده
قرار على السودان
واحد العناصر الاركان الرئيسيه لهذا
القرار هو تشكيل لجنه متابعه وتواصل
واتصال من
مصر مملكه العربيه السعوديه والامين العام
[موسيقى]
الدعوه الى عوده سوريا الى شغل مقعدها في
الجامعه العربيه هو ايضا قرار بينشئ لجنه
متابعه من
مصر
والسعوديه
والاردن والعراق والامين العام وهو ايضا
وهي لجنه ايضا مهمتها المتابعه
تسويه القضيه السوريه
عوده سوريا الى شغل المقعد
هي بدايه
حركه وليست نهايه مطاف بمعنى انه مسار
التسويه للازمه السوريه هتاخذ مرحله من
الاجراءات والتدرج فيها ومهمه هذه اللجنه
هي متابعه هذه
الاجراءات ايضا هي ليست
بقرار
لاقامه علاقات طبيعيه بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا هذا قرار سيادي لكل دوله على حده
نحن نتحدث في هذا القرار عن
شغل المقعد وتشكيل اللجنه للتواصل مع
الحكم في سوريا والحكومه السوريه
فعوده سوريا هي بدايه للطريق وليس نهايه
للمسار
هذا لا يفترض ان الازمه السوريه حلت بل
على العكس هو يدخل الجانب العربي لاول مره
منذ سنوات في تواصل مع الحكومه السوريه
للبحث في كافه عناصر المشكله
الضاغطه على سوريا وهناك عناصر كثيره جدا
تم مناقشتها سواء في
عمان او في اجتماع
جده
وبالقرار
بيتناول
الاقتراب من المشكله السوريه بشكل تدريجي
وهو بالتالي قرار واقعي للغايه لانه يعلم
انه لا يمكن تسويه هذه القضيه في يوم او
في شهر فهي هتاخد وقتها
هذا يعني انه الحكومه السوريه سوف تتواجد
في كافه مدوئات
الجامعه العربيه ومنظمتها الاقليميه
واجتماعاتها الوزاريه ما بين اجتماعات
المندوبين الى
القمه وسوف نقوم باخطار
الجانب السوري ربما مساء اليوم ربما صباح
باكر
رسميا بهذا القرار وعناصره كلها شكرا
جزيلا سياده الرئيس
الامانه العامه ولرئاسه الجلسه فيما يتعلق
بهذا القرار البند الثلاثه والبند الخمسه
المتعلق بالعوده في ثلاثه بنتحدث عن مسار
هو مجرد خطوه على طريق كما اشرت حضرتك وهو
كان نتيجه لجهود سابقه تم البناء عليها في
قرار 2011 كان هناك اشاره الى ان تجميد
عضويه سوريا في الجامعه العربيه مرتبط
بعدم تعاطيها مع ما سمي انذاك بالمبادره
الحل العربي هل حصلتم سواء عبر اللقاءات
التمهيديه في جده او في عمان على التزام
من الطرف السوري بان يتعاطى ايجابيا مع
هذا الامر لانه المعترضين على هذا القرار
كانوا يرون ان على جانب السوره ان يقدم
ايضا خطوات في هذا الاتجاه هل لدى الامانه
العامه او رئاسه الدوره اتصال بالجانب
السوري يعني يعطي من خلالها هذا الجانب
السوري التزاما بالمضي قدما في حل المشكله
الاساسي للازمه السوريه ومن ثم يصبح هذا
القرار يعني ذي جدوى ومن الممكن البناء
عليه
واضح انه القرار اشار بشكل واضح الى
المخرجات الخاصه بالاجتماع الذي عقد في
الجده ومتلاهم الاجتماع عقد في عمان
والبيان الذي صدر وانضم اليه وزير
الخارجيه سوريا وهذا البيان متضمن كافه
الابعاد الخاصه بالازمه السوريه
وضروره التفاعل الايجابي مع كل المكونات
سواء كانت سياسيه او انسانيه
وقضايا اخرى
ذاتها تاثير على المحيط الاقليمي وقضيه
تواجد القوات الاجنبيه
وضروره تفاعل سواء الحكومه او كافه
المكونات السياسيه السوريه من اجل التوصل
الى الحلول التي
يرتديها الشعب السوري وتؤدي الى استعاده
سوريا لكامل سيادتها واستقراره امنها
ووفقا للمرجعات الدوليه
والمقررتها واعلى راسها القرار 22 54
فما تم ابداءه من قبل الحكومه السوريه
خلال اللقاءات الثنائيه التي عقدت قبل
الاجتماعين ثم تداول الذي تم خلال
الاجتماعات يؤكد وكما تحدثت في الكلمه في
الجلسه بان هناك مسؤوليه تقع على الجميع
وانما هو اسكاء
انا واياكم المؤتمر الصحفي من القاهره
لامين عام الجامعه العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
وسامح شكري وزير الخارجيه المصري بعد
نهايه الاجتماع الطائر التشاوري لوزراء
الخارجيه العرب والذي بحث ملفين مهمين هما
ملف الاول هو ملف عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه وقد جاء في بيان الجامعه العربيه
السعوديه القرار العربي بعوده سوريا
اعتبارا من اليوم
واشار اليه ايضا ربما امين عام الجامعه
العربيه في ثنائي هذا المؤتمر بان هذه
العوده لا تعني نهايه للازمه السوريه وهي
خطوه على الطريق ينبغي من خلال اللجنه
المشكل
المكونه من مصر والسعوديه والاردن والعراق
زائد الامين العام للجامعه العربيه مت
ابعه تسويه القضيه السوريه والملفات
المتعلقه بكل جوانب هذه الازمه
مواجهه اضافه طبعا الى الملف ملف الازمه
في السودان كان احمد ابو الغيط
ايضا تحدث عن ان النقطه الاهم ربما في
بيان الجامعه العربيه ينص على تشكيل لجنه
متابعه واتصال مكونه من مصر والسعوديه
بالاضافه الى الامين العام للتواصل مع
اطراف النزاع والقوه الفاعله الدوليه
للتوصل الى حلول لهذه الازمه
لقد اكدت ايضا الجامعه العربيه ان
المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه لوقف اطلاق
النار في السودان تستحق الدعم والتمسك بها
وقبل ذلك رحبت تلاليه الثلاثيه التي تضم
الاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده وايجاد
بالمبادره السعوديه الامريكيه لحل النزاع
في السودان وقال بيان صادر عن الاليه
الثلاثيه انها تامل ان تسفر المحادثه في
جده عن تفاهمات تؤدي الى وقف شامل ليطلق
نار ما يتيح تقديمه مساعدات انسانيه عاجله
للمدني
وجددت الاليه الثلاثيه مناشدتها لكلا
الطرفين ان يوقف الاعمال العدائيه على
الفور
اقليم دارفور ينضم الينا الصحه في صالح
ابو علامه سيد صالح مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه اولا كيف تعلق على ما جاء في بيان
الجامعه العربيه حول السودان في الاجتماع
الطائر لوزراء الخارجيه العرب اليوم
نعم هي خطوه مهمه تجاهل السودان فيما
يتعلق بالاوضاع الان في السودان لكن هذه
الخطوه تحتاج الى تدخلات عاجله نعلم بان
الوضع في السودان يزداد سوء كل يوم لذلك
ارى بان التدخل يجب ان يكون عاجل وفورا
فيما يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار وقف
العدائيات حتى هذه اللحظه العدائيات
المستمره في الخرطوم وهنالك عمليات عسكريه
مستمره لذلك يجب ان تكون الخطوات متسارعه
حتى تتوقف العدائيات
ومن ثم معالجه الاوضاع الانسانيه في
السودان الوضع لا يحتمل ابدا المزيد من
المداولات مزيد من الحديث ومزيد من
الاجتماعات نعلم بان هنالك نزوح كبير
وهنالك
ايضا وضع انساني يحتاج الى التدخل
مستشفيات متوقفه ايضا هنالك
احياء عديده تعاني من انقطاع المياه
والكهرباء حتى المسارات الانسانيه تحتاج
الى مراقبه تحتاج الى تدخل لذا الوضع في
السودان يحتاج الى تدخل عاجل نعم هذه
الخطوه خطوه مهمه يجب ان تنزل مباشره الى
ارض الواقع حتى تغير في الاوضاع الماثره
الان في السودان شكرا جزيلا لكم الصحه في
صالح ابو حلب
في رابع بعد قليل
السعوديه تسجل نمون في الناتج المحلي بنحو
اربعه في المئه خلال الربع الاول من العام
الجاري
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشف التقرير الرباعي
لاداء الميزانيه العامه للسعوديه ان
الايرادات بلغت 200 وثمانين مليار و900
مليون ريال في مبالغ حجم الانفاق
283 و 800 مليون ريال وبذلك يبلغ عجز
الميزانيه مليارين وتسعمائه مليون ريال
وفقا للتقرير فان الايرادات النفطيه في
الربع الاول بلغت 178 مليارا و600 مليون
ريال بينما بلغت الايرادات غير النفطيه
102 مليار ريال وكانت الحكومه السعوديه قد
توقعت تسجيل فائض بسته عشر مليار ريال في
ميزانيه العام الحالي باكملهم
الجبيل ينضم الينا عضو مجلس الشورى
السعودي المحلل الاقتصادي فضل الله معي في
نشره الرابعه كيف تقرا هذه الارقام بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين
ارقام متميزه خاصه فيما يتعلق بالاقتصاد
غير النفطي ونموه اللافت اضافه الى
الايرادات غير النفطيه التي نمت بشكل واضح
ايضا وهذا امر غايه في الاهميه هناك تسجيل
عجز محدود جدا ولكن يعزى هذا العجز الى
ارتفاع كبير في
النفقات الراسماليه لتصل الى 75% وبالتالي
كان هناك انفاق توسعي على المشروعات وعلى
التنميه وعلى متطلبات رؤيه المملكه 2030
بشكل عام انا اعتقد الارقام مبشره في
الربع الاول خاصه في جانب الاقتصاد غير
النفطي والايرادات غير النفطيه التي يعتمد
عليها بشكل كبير في تحقيق الاستدامه
المهنيه النقاط المتعلقه كذلك بزياده في
المصروفات
مقارنه بالايرادات هناك كيف يمكن نظر الى
اهميتها في اي
المجالات هذه المصروفات تمت وانعكاسات
ايضا على الاقتصاد السعودي بشكل عام
الاول فيما يتعلق بالتوسع في الانفاق ونحن
نعلم ان هناك رؤيه المملكه عشرين ثلاثين
هناك استراتيجيه واضحه هناك برامج
ومشروعات مرتبطه بالرؤيه وهناك ايضا برامج
تطلق تباعا ومشروعات كبرى هذه تحتاج الى
انفاق توسع وبالتالي هناك مواءمه حقيقيه
بين الاتفاق التوس بين الانفاق العام
وارتفاعه بنسبه 75% على سبيل المثال للحصر
وبين متطلبات المرحله القادمه هو مرحله
التاسيس التي تحتاج الى انفاق اكبر قبل ان
يقطف ثمارها المحور الثاني مما يرتبط
بالانعكاس على الاقتصاد الكلي اليوم نشهد
نحن نموا في الاقتصاد بلغه 3.9 من 10%
وبالتالي هذا النمو وانما يحزى
الضخفي في الاقتصاد والانفاق الذي تمارسه
الحكومه خاصه وان الاقتصاد السعودي ما زال
يعتمد بشكل كبير على الانفاق الحكومي هذا
من جانب من جانب اخر نركز ايضا على نمو
الانشطه غير النفطيه وصلت الى 5.8
وبالتالي هذا يعني ان الاصلاحات الهيكليه
والاصلاحات الاقتصاديه تمشي في طريقها
الصحيح وتعطي نتائج مبشره بالخير هذا بشكل
عام اسعار النفط كيف اثرت على هذه الارقام
ايضا طبعا اللافته
ينخفض الثلاثه بالمئه وبالتالي انخفاض
اسعار النفط يؤثر على الايرادات النفطيه
ويؤثر على الايرادات الكليه هذا من جانب
الاسعار ولكن هناك ايضا جانب اخر مؤثر وهو
ما يتعلق بخفض انتاج النفط وبالتالي هذا
يخفف في الايرادات المملكه تنتهج سياسه
نفطيه متوازنه تحقق فيها مصلحه المنتجين
والمستهلكين ايضا وتسعى دائما الى تحقيق
التوازن الامثل بالسوق وهذا التوازن يتطلب
في بعض الاحيان رفع الانتاج وفي بعض
واحيانا اخرى خفض الانتاج في الربع الاول
من العام الحالي تطلبت الاسواق العالميه
خفضا في الانتاج ليكون هناك توازن امثل
وبالتالي تحملت المملكه جزء من هذا
الانخفاض وبالتالي انخفاض في ايراداتها
الكليه وهذا ما يعزى له انخفاض الايرادات
النفسيه بالنسبه 3% شكرا جزيلا لك من
الجبيل العضو مجلس الشورى السعودي المحل
الاقتصادي يفضل البعينين
لقد كشفت ايه الاحصاء السعوديه عن نمو في
الناتج المحلي
بثلاثه.9 من العشره في المئه خلال الربع
الاول من العام الجاريه 2023 وفقا
للتقديرات الاوليه لهيئه الاحصاء فان هذا
النمو في الناتج المحلي للسعوديه يعود الى
ارتفاع الانشطه غير النفطيه التي سجلت
نموا بنحو السته في المئه والخدمات
الحكوميه التي نمت هي الاخرى بنحو 5% فضلا
عن نمو بواحد فاصله ثلاثه من العشره في
المئه في القطاع النفطي
قد شهدت العاصمه السعوديه الرياض بدا اول
اعمال التسجيل العيني للعقار في حي الفلاح
الهيئه السعوديه للعقار اوضحت ان السجل
العقاريه الذي سيتم منحه لجمع عقارات الحي
بعد الانتهاء من تسجيلها تعتبر امتدادا
لمرحله الصكوك الالكترونيه الحاليه لجميع
العقارات السكنيه والتجاريه والزراعيه
والحكوميه وان التسجيل الاول لعقارات او
للعقارات سيكون متاحا بشكل مجاني عن
الطريق منصه سجل العقاري الالكترونيه
ويحمل صك التسجيل الملكيه الجديده بيانات
واوصافا للعقار وحالته وما يتبعه من حقوق
والتزامات وجميع التصرفات العقاريه التي
تطرا عليهم
من رياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي اهلا عبد المحسن كيف سيتم
العمل الان في حي الفلاح بعد بدء اعمال
التسجيل العيني للعقار في هذا الحي
نعم
الف واحد من الاحياء او المرحله الاولى
التي تم تطبيق فيها هذا النظام لاحظنا
الكثير من اللوحات الارشاديه التي تعرف
السكان على نظام التسجيل العيني للعقار
وتطلب منهم من الدخول والتعرف عليه اكثر
وكذلك عمليه التسجيل العيني
للعقار التي بدات اليوم عبر عدد من
المسجلين العينين للعقار الذين تم تحديدهم
من قبل الهيئه العامه للعقار وفي هذه
المرحله الاولى بالاضافه الى مراحل اخرى
سيتم زياده اعداد المسجلين العالميين الذي
بلغ عددهم في المرحله الاولى ما يقرب على
200 الى 200 مسجل عيني وسنتحدث اكثر عن
هذا النظام مع الاستاذ تيسير مفرج المتحدث
الرسمي للهيئه العامه للعقار استاذ تيسير
نرحب فيك او اولا نتحدث عن نظام العيني
لتسجيل العقار
وبدايه ما هو هذا النظام بالاضافه الى ذلك
ما هو الفرق بينه وبين الصكوك الاعتياديه
السجل العقاري هو منهجيه عالم متعارف
عليها لتوثيق الملكيات سجل العقاري هو
يعطي لكل عقار هويه خاصه فيه ورقم خاصه
فيه هو رقم الهويه العقاريه او رقم العقار
او رقم السجل العقاري هذا الرقم هو سيكون
المرجعيه الاساسيه لكل العقارات المملكه
العربيه السعوديه رقم واحد لكل عقار بغض
النظر عن المالك هو تعدد الملاك بعد فتره
من الزمن السجل العقاري يعتمد اعتماد كلي
على البيانات الاساسيه في المرصوده في
الهيئه العامه للعقار عن طريق المسح او عن
طريق البيانات الجيو مكانيه وايضا عن طريق
المسح الميداني وايضا عن طريق الصكوك وعن
طريق الخرائط الخاصه بامانات بالمناطق تم
اختيار حي الفلاح الحقيقه كاول حي للسجل
العقاري بناء على اكتمال هذه البيانات
بيانات الصكوك الالكترونيه بيانات
البيانات الوجيه ومكانيه الخاصه بالبسح
والتصوير الجوي وايضا البيانات اللي على
الواقع واكتمال هذه البيانات في هذا الحي
فبالتالي تم اختيارك كحي اول في مدينه
الرياض سيتبع بمشيئه الله مجموعه من
الاحياء داخل مدينه الرياض وجده والدمام
في هذا العام 20 23 ثم ستستمر على كافه
مناطق المملكه حتى نستكمل قرابه الثمانيه
مليون عقار هذا المشروع ضخم جدا سيوثق
ثمانيه مليون عقار على مستوى المملكه ومنح
كل هذه العقارات رقم واحد العقار اذا
الفلاح والحي الاكمل ربما لبدا هذه
العمليه تحدث عن الاثر الاقتصادي لهذا
النظام ما هي ابرز النتائج الايجابيه على
الاقتصاد سواء كان على مستوى حي الفلاح او
غيره من الاحياء التي سيتم فيها تطبيق هذا
النظام اليوم مرحله تاريخيه في الثقه في
السوق العقاري السعودي السجل العقاري هو
الاداه الرئيسيه اليوم اللي راح تمنح او
ترفع نسبه الثقه والموثوقيه في العقارات
السعوديه هذا بحد ذاته سيكون محفز لكثير
من العمليات العقاريه دقه البيانات توفرها
اكتمالها من خلال السجل العقاري هذا كله
سيكون محفز اقتصادي كبير جدا في القطاع
العقاري وبالتالي احنا نتكلم عن الثقه
والموثوقيه بشكل سريع كيف يتم عمليه
التسجيل لوحات كثيره ارشاديه هل هي تسجيل
بشكل يدوي عبر
مندوبينكم او بشكل الكتروني اليوم حنا
ناتي رسالتنا لكل سكان حي الفلاحة واي حي
يتم اختياره كمنطقه مستفيده مستقبلا هو
التسجيل عن طريق المنصه الرسميه للسجل
العقاري من خلال الموقع الرسمي يتم تسجيل
ربطها بالنفاذ الوطني ثم ستكون كل
البيانات موجوده ومسجله وبالتالي تكون انت
قد سجلت عقاريا
اذا خالد كما تشاهد هذه هي اللوحات
الارشاديه التي بدا يلاحظ
في الرابعه بعد الفصل فعاليات مهرجان
افلام السعوديه تستمر في الظهران 78 عرضا
سينمائيا حتى الخميس المقبل
بان السبيل الوحيد للتسويه هو الحل
السياسي بملكيه سوريه خالصه
بعد 12 عاما من العزله تعود سوريا للجامعه
العربيه مع دعوات للحكومه السوريه بحل
سياسي وعوده لاجئين
السودان يعيش رابع اسابيع النزاع المسلح
رغم الهدنه اشتباكات في الخرطوم واجراء
مستمر الى جده
السعوديه تعلن ميزانيه الربع الاول من
العام الجاري تسجيل عجز بنحو ثلاثه
مليارات ريال
توقفت يعقوب مع اخواته خطا طبي يرد علاقه
بين اسرتين تركيا والسعوديه زلزال تركيا
يعيد قصه طفلين الى الوجه
فعاليات مهرجان افلام السعوديه تستمر في
الظهران 78 عرضا سينمائيا حتى الخميس
المقبل
اهلا بكم من جديد من اجرام الى انطاكيا
تكاثف اسره سعوديه وتركيه لمواجهه
التاثيرات مريره سببها زلزال السادس من
فبراير علاقه الاسرتين تعود لعقدين عندما
حدث خطا طبي واستبدلوا طفليهما بمستشفى
حادثه لا زالت تفاصيلها تؤثر على حياتهم
قبل اكثر من سنه حدثت قصه يتذكرها الجميع
عندما استبدلت اسرتين سعوديه وتركيه
طفليهما بعد خطا في مستشفى جنوبيه
السعوديه هنالك في نجران اليوم وبعد 20
سنه هذا هو يعقوب اليامي يعين رفقه والده
السابق يوسف التركي منزلهم المدمر في
انطاكيا بعد زلزال السادس من فبراير حسينا
بهزه يعني البيت يهتز رح نتشمعنا في مكان
واحد جلسنا بعد ما وقف الزلزال بشوي
حاولنا نخرج مع مع الباب ننزل الدور عشان
نساعد جدي
وفيه كانت هناك مرت عمي واولادها حاولنا
نساعدهم وخرجهم من البيت
بعد ما خرجنا يعني كان الجو ممطر وكان في
جيراني يبغون مساعدات وحاولنا نساعد بعض
الجيران اللي كانوا جنبنا بعدين خلينا
العائله وبعدها من البيت
يوسف التركي الذي احتضن يعقوب بعد ولادته
بدقائق اعتقادا منه انه ابنه قبل ان يكتشف
عكس ذلك بسنوات كان في نجران وقت الزلزال
هرع الى تركيا ولم يكن وحيدا بل رافقه
والد يعقوب السعودي محمد اليامي
وقفت شغله معاي وقف يعقوب مع اخواته مع
عائلته مع اهله يعني
من كل متفرقين من شيء
توسلات الاهل والاصدقاء ليعقوب بالعوده
الى السعوديه بعد وقوع الزلزال لم تكن
مجديه
كلموني قال ابغاك الحمد لله بخير
وكلنا سليمين نحمد الله لكن ما اقدر انزل
عندكم يعني لازم اساعد اللي هنا لازم
اساعدها
خطا ومستشفى نجران قبل نحوي عقدين من
الزمان جعل ليعقوب اخا اسمه علي لازال
يتقن شيئا من اللهجه النجرانيه يحمل
الجنسيه السعوديه ويعيش في العاصمه
التركيه انقره
وانا يعقوب ساعدنا اهلنا في الخروج من
المنزل
واخذناهم الى منطقه امنه بعدها
شعلنا النار كي نتفه
تقريبا بعد 15 ساعه كذا توصلنا على اهلنا
في السعوديه
عشان نحضرهم من الخير
يعقوب قدر له ان يعيش حياتين في نجران
كمقيم وفي تركيا كمواطن في السعوديه انا
مقيم هناك واعاني في بعض الامور اذا رحت
مكان ولا حاجه يعني يكون السعوديين
يبدونهم قدام وانا اكون دائما في الخلف
ونفس الكلام ينطبق في تركيا يعني ما اقدر
اسوي اي شيء
في السعوديه ابغى اقدم
كذا
فقط السعوديين ما يقولون علي باقي على
جنسيته السعوديه في اسم ابو السعودي
ويعقوب باقي على جنسيته التركيه في اسمي
انا يعني نبغى اقل حاجه نعدلني اياها في
كل واحد في اسمه جنسيتين يعني
اخذنا يعقوب الى حيث سينام اليوم برفقه
والده التركي خيمه لاحد اقربائهم الاتراك
وقادنا الى خيم المساعدات السعوديه التي
وصلت انطاكيا وبعثت فيه الحنين لوطنه لابد
يعني لقدك تشوف دولتك الام تساعد دوله
ثانيه او مثل ما تضطرين من الزلزال في
تركيا وفي سوريا يعني يتشرف الواحد ويعتزل
بدولته انها تساعدوا الناس محتاجين
لا يشعروا يعقوب بالغربه في تركيا يتجول
بين اقربائه الاتراك ويسير دوما برفقه
والده التركي الذي لا يفرق بينه وبين
ابنائه عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه انطاكيا
السعوديه تستمر فعاليات مهرجان اقلام
السعوديه بنسختها التاسعه المقامه في مركز
الملك عبد العزيز الثقافي العالمي اثراء
يشهد المهرجان تقديم ثمانيه وسبعين عرضا
لافلام متنوعه ضمن 48 مجموعه عرض واربع
مجموعات الاطفال ويتاح من خلاله ايضا
للمره الاولى لمشاهدته ثمانيه افلام عبر
اجهزه الواقع الافتراضي المسممه ما خصيصا
لخلق تجربه سينمائيه مختلفه
الظهران مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
عبد الرحمن حياك الله ما هو العنوان
الابرز لهذا اليوم في مهرجان افلام
السعوديه في اثراء
نعم اليوم جميع الحضور في مهرجان افلام
السعوديه هنا في مركز الملك عبد العزيز
العالمي الثقافي اثراء ينتظرون الفيلم
الوثائقي قصه ملك الصحافه الذي يرصد حياه
وتفاصيل جديده للاستاذ تركي السديري رئيس
تحرير صحيفه الرياض سابقا رحمه الله والذي
سيكون ايضا بحضور نخبه من الاعلاميين
والصحفيين وايضا جزء من افراد عائله
الاستاذ تركي السديري طبعا الحديث اكثر
خالد عن المهرجان وعن تفاصيلي وعن
المبادرات ورش العمل ايضا ينضم للاستاذ
احمد الملا مدير مهرجان افلام السعوديه
اهلا بك استاذ احمد اولا ما هو المختلف في
هذه النسخه التاسعه عن النسخ السابقه شكرا
لكم على الحضور حقيقه دائما تشاركون
فرحتنا وفرح الصنع الافلام السعوديه في
هذه الدوره وكل الدورات السابقه ما يختلف
حقيقه هو
ان ليس هناك اختلاف هناك
تطور هادئ
متواصل لكن ليس قفزات سريعه هناك
اهتمام بكل ما حققه المهرجان في دوراته
السابقه ويكون هناك تكون اضافات سريعه
الافتراضي هذه جديده هذه نسخه ثمانيه
افلام تقريبا صحيح هو طبعا ما يتحقق في
اثراء كشريك
لجمعيه السينما في
تنظيم هذا المهرجان ودعم هيئه الافلام ان
هناك في البلازا دائما يعني عروض او يعني
هناك السوليشن ما يسمونه لاشياء
ملموسه ياتي لها الزائر العام ويستطيع ان
يستمتع فيها
في طريقنا للسوق الانتاج
الانتاج هذا العام ايضا هل هناك شيء جديد
اضافه جديده عن العوامل السابقه بالتاكيد
تجربتنا العام الماضي استفدنا منها وكانت
ناجحه بشكل كبير جدا كان هناك 16
بوت للشركات
كان هناك طلب كبير جدا تقريبا اكثر من 100
طلب لشركات فرفعنا عدد البوثات بتصميم
جمالي وابداعي
اصبح هناك عشرين نسعى هذا السوق الانتاج
يخدم اغراض عديده جدا يعني احد منها انه
يكون
والملتقى النهاري لصنع الحركه يعني خليه
نحل وايضا كذلك في المسرح في الخلف هناك
برامج متواصله طوال ايام المهرجان
الثمانيه طيب استاذ احمد تحدثني انه
اصدارات جديده هذا العام كتب تتعلق
بالسينما والصناعه ايضا حقيقه منه هي هي
انتباهها منذ الدوره الاولى وبدانا
بكتابين في الدوره الاولى في عام 2008 في
هذه الدوره الان الدوره التاسعه هناك 17
كتاب
تم اصداره والان يتم توزيعه على صنع
الافلام من مختلف ترجمات من مختلف اللغات
من الايطاليه والاسبانيه والفرنسيه
والانجليزيه وايضا تاليف عربي وايضا يعني
تاليف سعودي لكتاب سعوديين مهتمين
ونساعدهم في عمليات توفيق استاذ احمد
مهرجان رائع واستمر ويطور عام بعد عام
استاذ احمد خالد كما شاهدنا حقيقه يعني
خليه نحل متنوعه واسماء كبيره من الفنانين
السعوديين وغير السعوديين ايضا ومن جميع
انحاء العالم لحضور هذا المهرجان الذي
يتطور اكثر فاكثر عاما بعد عام شكرا لك
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مركز اثراء في
الظهران
الشمس هي اول ساعه كونيه عرفها الانسان
تقويم مع خالد سعد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشمس اول ساعه كونيه عرفها الانسان لحساب
ساعات النهار والنجوم اول ساعه كونيه
عرفها الانسان لحساب ساحات الليل فاذا
اشرقت الشمس ينتشر ضوءها وينعدم الليل
واذا غربت تبدا النجوم تتلالا بالاضاءه
فالشمس وحده ومع ذلك تفرش ضوءها وينعدم
السواد والنجوم الاف ومع ذلك يبقى سوادا
الليل هو المسيطر خليك مثل الشمس واضحه
وصريحه وهدفه معروف والشمس لا تغطى بغربال
كالشمس في كبد السماء وضوءها يغشى البلاد
مشارقا
ومغاربه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فالشمس هي اساس الخليقه فمع شروقها تنتعش
الحياه ومع غروبها تسكن بل هي حجر زاويه
في فسيولوجيه الحياه برمتها ولاهميتها
ذكرها المولى في 33 موضعا في كتابه ولها
مكانه عليا عند العرب اللي يحب الشمس
يبكيها الغروب واللي يحب الليل يضحك للقمر
واللي يحب انسان ما يقدر يتوب لا صار هذا
الحب يسواله
عمر
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
لان السبيل الوحيد للتسويه هو الحل
السياسي بملكيه سوريه خالصه بعد 12 عاما
من العزله سوريا تعود للجامعه العربيه
ودعوات للحكومه السوريه بحالم سياسي وعوده
لاجئين
السودان
سابع النزاع المسلح رغم الهدنه اشتباكات
مستمره في الخرطوم
السعوديه تعلن ميزانيه الربع الاول من
العام الجاري وتسجيل عجز بنحو ثلاثه
مليارات ريال
خطا طبي وطدوا علاقه بين اسرتين تركيا
وسعوديه الزلزال يعيد قصه طفلين نجران الى
الواجهه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات